Polonia es uno de los países más importantes
de Europa del Este.
Tal y cómo ya os contamos aquí en VisualPolitik
[en un vídeo que os dejo en la descripción],
su proceso de crecimiento y desarrollo durante
las últimas décadas ha sido vertiginoso.
(Desde 1992 la economía polaca ha crecido
a un media de más del 4% anual.
A nivel europeo, Polonía ha sido el país
más prospero tan solo por detrás de Irlanda,
Estonia y Letonia.
De hecho, aunque pueda resultar sorprendente
dadas sus circunstancias históricas, lo cierto
es que los polacos se situan ya en la media
europea en cuanto a riesgo de pobreza.)
Es decir, en otras palabras, Polonia ha sido
uno de los países que mejor ha sabido digerir
la transición política, económica y social
a la que los antiguos países de la orbita
soviética se tuvieron que enfrentar tras
el colapso de la URSS.
Sin embargo, amigos, esperad un momento, porque
no es oro todo lo que reluce.
Los números, las magnitudes, los datos económicos
son muy buenos, de eso no hay la menor duda.
En ese aspecto el éxito es innegable… Pero,
¿qué sucede en el terreno político y social?
Pues, amigos, ahí ya es cuando nos encontramos
que las cosas dejan de ser de color de rosas.
Especialmente si os preocupan las libertades
civiles.
[Ya sabéis eso de que es más fácil cambiar
una economía que una sociedad. Lo segundo
lleva mucho más tiempo]
El caso es que como vamos a ver, Polonia,
es probablemente junto a Hungría el país
más conservador y tradicionalista de toda
la Unión Europea. ¿Una prueba?
("El cristianismo es parte de nuestra identidad
nacional, la Iglesia [católica] fue y es
el predicador y el soporte del único sistema
de valores comúnmente sostenido en Polonia.
Fuera de eso ... solo hay nihilismo" Jaroslaw
Kaczynski, Ex-Primer Ministro y Presidente
del Partido en el Gobierno “Ley y Justicia”)
Pero no solo eso, también es un país que
se ha caracterizado por impulsar una agenda
política que para muchos choca directamente
con los principios de la Unión Europea.
¿Queréis conocer más a fondo que diantres
ocurre en Polonia? ¿Cómo de conservadora
es su sociedad? ¿Cuál es esa agenda que
se ha convertido en toda una pesadilla, un
dolor de cabeza para las autoridades europeas?
Pues… Atentos.
Amigos, en Polonia si no eres católico, blanco
y heterosexual, entonces creo que vas a tener
un problema.
Lo más seguro es que de una forma u otra
te sientas rechazado por buena parte de la
sociedad… Y, sí, también por el gobierno:
(El partido oficialista de Polonia aviva el
sentimiento anti-LGTB antes de las elecciones.)
(Elecciones polacas: el líder del partido
mayoritario apunta a los derechos de los homosexuales
como una amenaza para la sociedad. BBC)
En este país el rechazo a todo lo
que escapa al modelo tradcional de familia
cristina está muy presenta en la sociedad.
Por ejemplo, en la mayoría de países europeos
que el partido en el gobierno tilde de “amenaza
para la sociedad” a las personas LGTBI sería
algo impensable. Sin embargo aquí es algo
que está a la orden del día.
Simplemente, Polonia es así.
Ahora bien, ¿Cómo puede un país como este,
que en cierto modo promueve el acoso a las
minorias, encajar en un proyecto como el de
la Unión Europea? Ese es el gran dilema.
(La política polaca resulta en ocasiones
dificil de entender.
Por un lado, los polacos eligen y reeligen
a un partido nacionalista, anti-inmigración
y hómofobo, es decir, que se enfrenta a todo
lo que aparentemente significa el proyecto
comunitario, para dirigir el país.
Pero, por otro lado, la sociedad polaca es
una de las que tiene mejor impresión de la
Unión Europea. Fijaos:)
Claro que… Una cosa es tener una impresión
positiva de la Unión Europea y otra muy diferente
es estar dispuestos a cumplir con las directrices
que emanan de Bruselas.
Fijaos, fijaos cómo andan las cosas.
(Tribunal de Justicia de la UE: Polonia rompió
la ley de la UE con la reforma judicial. - Reuters)
(Polonia y Hungría rompen la ley de la UE
al rechazar acoger inmigrantes: los tribunales
advierten. - Reuters)
(Polonia desafía a Bruselas prometiendo adherirse
al carbón. “Polonia prioriza frenar su
dependencia de la energía rusa y continuar
con su dependencia del carbón, en lugar de
suscribirse al objetivo de cero emisiones
de la Unión Europea, en un movimiento que
pondrá a Varsovia rumbo a un choque frontal
contra Bruselas en política climática.”)
Vamos, que mucha Unión Europea y tal, pero
a la hora de la verdad, Polonia va por libre.
Pero… Entonces, ¿Cómo puede ser que la
imagen que los polacos tienen de la Unión
Europea sea tan buena?
Vamos a responder a esta pregunta, pero vayamos
paso a paso porque creedme cuando os digo
que la política polaca es una verdadera locura.
Hace ya más de dos años que en Bruselas
saltaron todas las alarmas por la supuesta
deriva antidemocrática de Polonia.
Sí, lo habeis escuchado bien.
¿Podría esatr Polonia experimentando un
viraje hacia el autoritarismo?
Respondamos a esta pregunta.
(LA DEMOCRACIA POLACA EN JAQUE)
Hay una cosa mucho, pero que mucho
más importante que la lealtad de Polonia
a la Unión Europea.
Me estoy refiriendo a la salud de la democracia.
Y lo cierto es que hoy por hoy la democracia
polaca no está pasando por sus mejores momentos.
Eso sí que es preocupante.
(Lo que más ha hecho sonar las alarmas ha
sido la deriva cada vez más personalista
del gobierno polaco.
Ahí está, por ejemplo, el intento de Jarosław
Kaczyński, el líder del partido PiS, por
reducir la edad de jubilación de los jueces
del Tribunal Supremo de los 70 a los 65 años.
Lo que supondría echar a la calle al 40%
de ellos, previsiblemente para ser sustituidos
por otros afines al partido.
Este cambio fue paralizado por el Tribunal
Europeo de Justicia por considerarlo como
un claro intento de control político sobre
el poder judicial. Sin embargo, a pesar de
ello, el gobierno ha continuado avanzando
en esa misma dirección por muchas vías diferentes.)
En 2017, por ejemplo el gobierno logro que
se aprobaran en el parlamento otras 3 leyes
muy pero que muy polémicas. Toda una apuesta
personal de Kaczyński para controlar el país.
Literalmente nada ni nadie se le iba a poner
por delante.
(Básicamente, entre las tres leyes se pretendía
no solo otorgar a los legisladores enormes
poderes sobre el Consejo General del Poder
Judicial sino también que el propio ministro
de justicia, que por cierto es también el
fiscal general, fuera quien nombrase a los
jueces y a los jefes de los tribunales locales.
Ya os podeis imaginar lo que supondría esto
en terminos de control político sobre los
tribunales.
Pero en un giro inesperado de los acontecimientos,
el presidente del país Andrzej Duda, afín
al PiS pero no perteneciente al partido, vetó
poco después dos de esas tres leyes, permitiendo
únicamente el nombramiento de los jefes de
los tribunales locales por el ministro de
justicia.)
Pero aquí no termina todo. Para nada.
La obsesión del gobierno por controlar la
justicia es algo constante.
(Polonia está purgando a sus fiscales - Foreign
Policy)
(La cámara disciplinaria para los jueces
polacos no es independiente, dice un asesor
superior del Tribunal Superior de Justicia
de la UE - Financial Times)
Y claro, llegados a este punto, muchos pensareis…
¿Y qué está haciendo la UE mientras tanto?
Pues… casi podemos decir que las autoridades
comunitarias han abierto una batalla frontal
contra Polonia por todas estas cuestiones.
De hecho, Bruselas activó por primera vez
en su historia el mecanismo de acción disciplinaria
contra un país miembro, algo que podría
terminar con la suspensión del derecho a
voto de Polonia en las decisiones europeas.
(Polonia es llevada ante la Corte Europa de
Justicia por presunto control político de
la justicia - Euronews)
[Y que quereis que os diga. Motivos parace
que sobran. Eso de ver a los políticos metiendo
mano en la justicia es algo muy pero que muy
preocupante.]
Ahora bien, los enfrentamienttos no se limitan
a este intento del gobierno polaco de asaltar
sus propios tribunales y terminar con la separación
de poderes.
Si a todo esto le sumamos las políticas de
tinte xenófobo, ultracatólico y homofobo
del Partido en el gobierno, entonces lo que
nos encontramos es con un país que se enfrenta
de raiz al rumbo que a tomado la Unión Europea
durante los últimos años.
(Los progresistas temen disturbios mientras
la Iglesia Católica polaca dobla su retórica
anti-gay - Reuters
El arzobispo de Cracovia, Marek Jedraszewski,
describió a Polonia como asediada por una
“plaga arco iris” de activistas por los
derechos de los gays que comparó con los
antiguos gobernantes comunistas de Polonia.)
Vamos, que tal y como veis los rumbos políticos
de la Unión Europea y de Polonia se parecen
tanto como un huevo a una castaña.
Pero, claro, llegados a este punto os preguntareis…
¡Pero, Alberto! Entonces, ¿por qué demonios
los polacos tinen una imagen tan buena de
la Unión Europea?
Pues, amigo… Lo cierto es que no todo lo
que tiene que ver con la Unión Europea disgusta
tanto al PiS, al Gobierno y por ende a la
sociedad polaca.
Hay algo que parece encantarles.
Atentos.
(DINERO, A TODOS NOS GUSTA EL DINERO)
Amigos, yo no soy muy fan de la Unión Europea
tal y como está construida… Pero los polacos
se llevan la palma.
¿Cumplir con las normativas comunitarias
en materia de garantias políticas y judiciales?
¿Respetar a las minorias o aceptar a los
6.200 solicitantes que Bruselas asigno a Polonia
en el reparto comunitario de refugiados?…
No de eso nada de nada, de ninguna manera.
Pero… el dinero… Ay, el dinero. Eso ya
es otra cosa.
El dinero de la UE por supuesto
que es bien recibido. Es recibido con los
brazos bien abiertos y una enorme sonrisa.
Y es que no hablamos precisamente de calderilla.
(Desde que Polonia se integró en la UE ha
recbido más de 110 mil millones de dólares
en ayudas comunitarias.
Tan solo el Fondo de Cohesión Europeo ha
otorgado a Polonia más 85 mil millones de
dólares para el periodo 2014 - 2020 con el
fin de financiar proyectos de infraestructuras
como autopistas y ferrocarriles.)
Y es que de hecho, Polonia es de todos los
países de la UE que reciben dinero del Fondo
de Cohesión el que mas recibe.
Por ciertto, frente a lo que se suele decir
este tipo de ayudas no han sido la clave del
despegue económico polaco, para nada. Pero
si que lo han apoyado.
Y es aquí cuando surge una pregunta que cada
vez más lideres políticos de la Unión Europea
se hacen, ¿Debería la UE condicionar las
ayudas comunitarias a que los países receptores
acepten cumplir con las propias normas y resoluciones
de la Unión?
¿Debería Bruselas congelar los fondos destinados
a Estados miembros con gobiernos antiliberales,
populistas y que no cumplan con sus responsabilidades?
Pues… parece que por ahí pueden ir los
tiros.
[Y en cierto modo tiene sentido, ¿no os parece?]
El caso es que justo ahora se está terminando
de negociar los términos y el reparto del
Fondo de Cohesión de la UE para el periodo
2021 - 2027. Y parece que Polonia podría
no salir bien parada.
De esta forma, de confirmarse esta noticia,
Polonia podría perder casi un cuarta parte
del dinero que recibe de la Unión Europea.
A
Aunque eso sí, con algo más de 64.000 millones
de dólares seguiría siendo el mayor receptor
de Fondos de Cohesión.
Pero ahora bien, no es lo que estais pensando.
Este recorte no tiene nada que ver con ningún
castigo ni nada por el estilo, sino con el
hecho de que Polonia, tal y como os contábamos
al principio del vídeo, es hoy un país más
rico, con mejores infraestructuras y está
más próximo a la media de desarrollo del
resto de la Unión Europea.
Con eso y con que el Brexit ha obligado a
Bruselas a ajustarse ligeramente el cinturon.
Ya no puede contar con la aportación que
cada año hacía el Reino Unido a las arcas
comunitarias.
En cualquier caso esto es algo que abre un
interrogante… Dada la tendencia política
de la sociedad polaca y su enorme distancia
con el rumbo marcado por Bruselas, ¿no supondrá
la reducción de fondos a Polonia que poco
a poco este país se aleje de la Unión? ¿No
explotarán los partidos nacionalistas polacas
estos recortes como una prueba de la intromisión
comunitaria?
Y la pregunta más importante de todas, ¿Son
la políticas polacas y húngaras, las políticas
de Europa del Este compatibles con la Unión
Europea? Dejadnos vuestras respuesras en los
comentarios.
Si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darla a like y por supuesto suscribiros
a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.